if you want to be a movement God you
need to know how to be hop but what is
bee hopping and how the hell do you do
it to stand on the biggest players of
your Region's toes
short for bunny hopping bee hopping is a
style of movement that involves
consistent inputs of the jump bind
matched with strafing although it has
its Origins way back in the 90s with
Quake B hopping truly hit its peak
thanks to the source engine mastering
this mechanic not only makes the user
more elusive but increases their speed
to frightening degrees gotta need it
thanks
all right so this is where the game
really opens up actually so how do you
pull it off run forward jump then let go
of your four key strafe Either left or
right and move your mouse in the same
direction just before you hit the ground
jump again once you're back in the air
strafe again this time in the opposite
direction as you do this a few times
you'll start to feel yourself move
faster but remember it's all about
timing and no one becomes a movement God
overnight